do me a favor I got three days left on
this probation when you got that gun on
you just don't tell me about it
plausible deniability oh do you mean
what do you think is gonna surprise fans
most about this fountain how funny it is
yeah I guess based on the trailer I hope
you are I hope you laugh more than you
think you will yeah I think the trailer
really prepares you for the weight of
the film which is good give me that
warning but you know 70% of it is just
funny and super entertaining it's oh I
love that that's gonna catch people
off-guard and have a good time yeah
trying to go back to jail $2.00 pounds
not Collins gun Sundance was a it was
the first film at Sundance what's been
the reaction that you've had so far it's
been great I mean people have said
incredibly nice things about it but I
think beyond that we have noticed the
conversations about the film extending
beyond the press rooms and the red
carpets and such so that's that's really
gratifying to get to as we've been
allowed to screen it in communities we
went to Atlanta last week we were in
Austin for South by I think getting to
sort of leave those screenings and have
conversations with folks who aren't
connected to the business just about
some of the issues that the film talks
about it's been very good that is the
life we live in and a bit since the
beginning and you know who's stuck in
that soil oil don't be who you is